Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yes.
Thank you, Ruffians, for being here with us for our 38th episode!
How did that happen?
38?
That's almost 40.
Honestly, it's almost 50.
We're almost there.
Before you know it, it'll be 50.
BAU BAU!
Well, for some Ruffians, you know, even though it's the 38th episode, it might be their first episode today.
Very happy.
To explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, it's the first FUWAMOCO Morning of this month.
Has there been a Pero Sighting?
Has a Ruffian seen one?
There has been.
It's been sort of a spooky Pero Sighting, but... How will this one be?
De-den.
A Ruffian spotted Pero working on doing some weight training at the gym.
Good for you for getting to the gym!
It takes a lot of effort, right?
I don't know, I don't think that, uh, Halo's source of motivation is the nicest.
But, I mean, being motivated is good, but positive sources are the best, you know?
Positive, yeah, that's true.
But, uh, you know, it's a new month.
And you know, it's not just any new month.
It's November, the second to last month of the year.
Second to last.
You know, that means that 2023,
It's almost over.
And maybe you had some goals you wanted to accomplish at the start of the year.
Like going to the gym.
But you know what?
You can still do that right now!
Yeah!
You know, if you go and work out hard at the gym, maybe you can grow strong and help protect those foam pedals.
Yeah.
You know, I think FUWAMOCO, we're pretty good at protecting your smile, maybe?
Maybe.
Yeah, we're rather agile, but not so much muscle.
Oh, are you sure?
Moco-chan, you think you're cool for this?
I'm pretty muscular, you just can't see it.
Maybe we should go to the gym too, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
Gym month!
November.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
BAU BAU!
Good luck and don't overdo it.
Don't overdo it.
I'm not talking to Pero, I'm talking to you.
Pero, he can throw his back out.
It's okay.
Yeah.
It's all good.
BAU BAU!
Well...
It's been a very exciting time recently.
And Ruffians, you know, it's been very spooky and a busy past Halloween week.
And within all the hustle and bustle and toil and jumble, you know, FUWAMOCO, we released our second cover song, CUTE!
YAKANOJO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
If you haven't listened to it, please go and do so.
And if you already have, do it again!
Yeah, your ears can take it, right?
Right!
It's a bit of a spooky song, you know, where more of like a FUWAMOCO's possessive yamere saikara comes out.
You say it like we have a younger side or something.
No.
We don't, right?
Ruffians.
No.
No such thing.
This is, you know... This is a different FUWAMOCO, right?
Different.
It's Halloween.
It's Halloween, okay?
Halloween means you dress up.
Why are you making those faces, Ruffians?
It's just, just, that's it, right?
Don't misunderstand our characters.
We'd be really happy if you could listen to our songs and share it with your friends too!
And!
Because of you!
It's already at 100,000 views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
But, you know, us and all the other creators and staff worked really hard to make it happen, so it'd mean a lot to us if you could love it lots too.
We want to continue to do lots of music and cool things, so...
BAU BAU!
More happy things!
Ruffians, you know that we wake up early to be able to produce FUWAMOCO Morning.
Get ready.
But today, we woke up even a bit earlier to be able to see a very special senpai's return!
Yeah!
Jumon-senpai!
Yes, my Jumon-senpai!
BAU BAU!
She made her return today after being away for over half of a year.
We're so happy!
Actually, when the starting screen began and Red Heart started playing, Moco-chan started crying really hard.
I was like, huh?
Moco-chan?
I was trying to be quiet.
Wait, it's just be quiet!
I was thinking about how happy and relieved the Heart-tubers be to have Heart-tubers senpai back!
As some Ruffians might know from our holotalk with Kiara-senpai, you know, Haachama-senpai was how we originally first learned about hololive.
Yeah.
You know, I saw a picture of Haachama-senpai on Twitter and I thought she was a really cute heroine from like a newly released Bishoujo game, like a visual novel.
And I wanted to play her because she looked really cute.
But then, I found out that she was a VTuber from a place called hololive!
Actually, to be completely honest, I was a little disappointed because I thought, you know, my brief dream would've been able to come true.
Like, it was just over.
Over, right there and then.
But, maybe!
Maybe!
Now it can come true!
I guess.
We're really happy that Haachama-senpai is back.
And we're glad to be able to see her newly premiered video for her original song that, you know, she wrote all herself.
It's nice to see the video after seeing her performance at 4th Fest too.
BAU BAU!
Welcome back Haachama-senpai!
Can I have a tissue?
No.
It's your fault for crying.
I'm dead.
I'm sorry!
Tears are all over my cheeks.
It's happy, right?
Welcome back, Haachama-san!
Welcome back!
And there's more happy news!
More happy news!
Ruffia!
Yeah.
Lots of happy.
Extra happy.
It's extra happy day today because it's DOG DAY!
Inu no hi!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAI!
Doesn't that just make your tail start wagging, Moco-chan?
It does.
It makes me proud to be a Demon Guard dog.
You know, it's our day today.
It's our day!
Ruffians, we hope that today inspires you to share your love about your favorite dogs in your life.
That's right.
And maybe if you go on a walk and you pass by a dog, you'll ask the owner if it's okay if you give it a few extra hugs.
That makes us really happy.
We're really happy to be the demon guard dog sisters of hololive.
Yeah!
We're really proud!
We hope that you'll also share this special day with some of our other doggie senpai too.
Like, Bailey us!
Because it's dog day today, Ruffians, let's all BAU BAU together for dog day.
Okay?
Are you ready?
BAU BAU!
Happy doggy!
Are you awake now?
That felt good.
We also have a bit of something we want to say.
Are we guilty about this?
No, but I wanted to check in on the Ruffians.
How are you feeling today?
You know, after a very busy Halloween and everything.
Did you wake up alright?
Are you good?
Are you awake now?
You don't feel a little lethargic or anything?
Sleepy.
The posture is a little tired.
Did you maybe eat too much candy?
Too many sweets?
Maybe even a few pon-de-rings?
Too much candy.
We hope you feel better soon if that's the case, but FUWAMOCO!
We have a bit of a confession.
Wow, FUWAMOCO!
You know, I confession.
We didn't have any candy!
No sweets.
We avoided all the howling tummy pains.
Ruffian great.
BAU BAU!
But it's really tempting though.
It is.
You know, especially now that the candy might be on sale.
Right?
It's nice because you can get a lot of variety, right?
That really only comes up this time of the year.
But you know, it's important to be careful with the sales because the leftover sale candies, they're probably the types that will make you hurt the most after eating too many.
Yeah.
So it's best to be nice to yourself and to your tummy too.
Right, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah, yeah, tummy.
Yeah, and if you end up eating only candy, no,
Ruffians, it's not good for you.
You know what the cure is, right?
Water.
But that helps, but... Vegetables.
That helps too.
The cure for a candy tummy is NATTO!
So watch out, Ruffians.
No.
Watch out, Moco-chan.
I'll have water, thank you.
BAU BAU!
Well, today is truly a day filled with only happy things.
Because Ruffians!
You know what?
Well, with it being the first day of the month and everything... You know what?
We did it!
We started this month on the right paw because... There's no miss on this channel!
No miss on this channel!
BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
You think we can make this the month of no misunderstandings?
No, no misunderstandings of November.
Wouldn't that be great?
It would be great, right, Ruffians?
Right!
Eh!
No!
Eh ya de.
I'd be really happy if we could turn a new leaf just as the leaves are falling from the trees too.
You know we can still make this the end of the year right.
We won't miss understanding.
It's our chance.
BAU BAU!
There's more exciting things happening!
More good things!
It's not just good things!
Today is just good things!
And a smile for you!
And for Moco-chan!
Happy things!
The best way to start off the month.
Well, Ruffians, you know, like I've mentioned over and over again, the end of October is a little busier than usual, so maybe some plans got a little bit changed here and there.
But, like usual, we wanted to do our end of the month BAU response to you on Twitter!
Hi!
Yes, so today, we'll be doing another voting response.
Yes, if you are not sure what a voting response is, it's simple.
Don't worry.
Simple.
For a certain amount of time, we will be doing our all to respond to your tweets.
Yeah, to your tweets.
We can't respond to every Ruffian's tweets, but we'll do our best.
We'll do our everything so we can respond to the most we can.
And how it goes, we'll put out a tweet
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO underscore EN.
You can see it right up there.
I forgot it.
Oh, it's right there, right.
I was panicking a bit.
What was it again?
And if you respond to that tweet using the hashtag #FUWAMOCO.
F-U-W-A-M-O-C-O.
In case you don't know how to spell.
Yeah, use that in your tweet.
We'll do our best to respond.
You know, which Ruffians we respond to is always completely random, but we do hope that you'll be able to
Send us a tweet and now we can send you a tweet back!
Yeah!
You know, the Rawr response is something that we really look forward to at the end of every month.
So we hope that you'll decide to pipe up from the pack and give us a tweet!
Yeah!
And the Rawr response, it starts at 8pm PT tonight.
And it will go for an hour and a half as usual.
Until 9.30pm PT.
So we hope that you'll tweet at us!
And we hope that we can tweet back at you too!
BAU BAU!
Don't forget Ruffians, you can set an alarm right now.
We might not have a stream tonight, but we have the alarm response.
We do, yeah.
So you know, we're never too far apart.
BAU BAU!
I guess it's the start of a new month, right?
It is.
A new leaf.
A new leaf?
The leaves are kind of old because they're falling.
We can... A pretty leaf.
Maybe not the newest.
Turn a new leaf and then fall.
But just in case some Ruffians needed it!
I... I wanted to say something.
Okay.
Ruffians!
Good morning!
It's November!
And I'm not November, I'm Mococo!
I think maybe you have an idea of what time of day and week it is hopefully, but in case you don't,
Yes!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And that means this time, you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
Halloween is over!
The spooky month is gone!
But... Unfortunately... I have one more scary thing to say.
The year is almost over!
Goodbye to 2023!
Soon.
You know, has it been a good year for you?
If it hasn't, you know what?
You can still make it good!
Even if things aren't going how you like them to.
Try to think, well, what can I do to make the situation better for me?
How can I learn from my experiences?
From these bumps?
You know, I know sometimes in the moment, it can be sort of hard.
It can be frustrating.
And it's okay to feel like that!
But, let's try to think on how I deal with these same kind of bumps next time they show up, okay?
Because, you know, they definitely will.
But!
Then, you'll be ready!
You'll be ready for them!
Because you're stronger.
I know you can do it.
Let's try to grow from every mistake and not let them take us down.
But, also, it's very important.
You have to make sure to give yourself some time to rest up, okay?
I know you can do it!
Let's do it all together, okay?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Oh, we're a bit close.
Let's take a step back.
Ruffians, do you feel ready to go for a run?
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan, let's have a look at some of our special submissions from our Ruffians.
Today is...
Another Doggie of the Day.
Doggie of the Day!
On dog day!
Right!
On dog day.
Let's see who we have!
Doggie of the Day today is... De-den!
I love the cute raw tummy hair.
Yeah, this is the dog of the day on dog day!
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I
I'm not really the kind to expose my tummy like this.
That's Moco-chan.
I would never do that.
Never, ever.
Ruffians!
I would never, ever do that.
Moco-chan would never show her tummy to you and give you some big puppy dog eyes and be like...
Tommy-kun.
I guess.
And how does Tomi-kun say BAU BAU?
I feel like it's a very sunny day.
Well, you have to first imagine you're on your back.
Is that maybe BAU BAU from the back?
Well, you know, this is our Doggie of the Day on Dog Day!
Yes.
Wow.
Look at their guarding skills.
Very efficient.
They're working hard all because they love you.
No matter how hard it might get.
When they, you know, they think of your smile and what you mean to them.
And that's what powers them to BAU BAU for another day.
And continue guarding.
Beautiful.
BAU BAU!
It's getting colder right now, but Ruffians, you're still going for walks, right?
Let's take a look where you at this time.
De-den!
A golden carpet!
Those trees sure had a lot of leaves, huh?
Right.
But this makes me want to go to New York City and join you on this walk!
It's so pretty.
We did go to 1920s New York the other day, right?
Does that count?
That's different.
Doesn't count.
We did go to the park.
True.
Battery Park.
But we hope that you'll be able to still go out and go on more pretty autumn walks like this for a few more weeks!
Yeah!
You need to walk down those golden carpets while you still can.
Right?
They've only been around for so long.
BAU BAU!
We got a question from a Ruffian.
The Question of the Day is... De-den!
Have you ever changed your outlook on life or attitude about something because of a story you experienced?
Your determination is so strong, it makes me very curious what kind of story has shaped who you are today.
Thank you for being so inspiring to us too!
BAU BAU!
This is a bit of a tricky question.
Well, there have been a lot of visual novels and anime that have influenced our outlook on life and maybe, you know, what we feel is important to us.
But I think it's kind of hard to pinpoint it, right?
But there are also lots of creators and other creators and anime and games
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
And also, the type of things that Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy sort of instilled on us from a young age are really important.
You know, the stuff like treat others as you'd like to be treated, and thinking of things from others' perspectives, being kind, understanding manners, all that stuff, etc.
You know?
Lots of things like that.
For us.
Those sort of things are just normal and the baseline of life, so it can be a bit difficult for us when something or someone sort of challenges those normals, you know?
It can make us a bit sad that those might not be normal for someone else, but you know, we don't have control over that, you know?
We're FUWAMOCO, we only have control over ourselves.
Continue to be stubborn for what we believe is right.
That's just the FUWAMOCO way, you know?
Did that answer your question at all?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
I don't know, maybe the answer is yes and no.
BAU BAU!
That was a good question, but a bit tricky, right?
FUWAMOCO, we are smart.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions, all your support, all your tweets.
Please remember, you know, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together.
We always are looking for more Doggie of the Days!
For seeing the kind of walks that you're going on, even though it's getting colder!
You know, getting questions!
Make sure you're warm when you go outside, okay?
Yeah.
Good time for questions, too!
Pero Sightings, if you happen to see Pero!
Please, don't forget, please...
Please don't forget.
Yeah, I almost said please forget.
Please forget!
Don't forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
And for our next dream.
We're gonna be taking the afternoon off a bit here while we work on some more homework.
But we still have the Rock n' Rawr Party, so don't forget.
Oh, not Rock n' Rawr Party.
Rawr in response.
Close Rawr in response.
Not Rock n' Rawr Party.
Rawr in response.
Don't get the Ruffians too excited, Moco-chan.
But our next dream is...
Super Mario Bros.
Wonder!
I'm really looking forward to it.
It's our first Mario game together with you, Ruffians!
Don't you love the beautiful thumbnail?
Yes, very beautiful.
At least we're Mario Bros Wonder.
Super Mario Bros Wonder, Moco-chan.
I apologize, I made a grave error.
Super Mario Bros Wonder!
We don't really have that much expectations, but we're just looking forward to having some pure Mario fun, you know?
We hope that you'll join us as we both play it together!
Both Moco-chan and I have a controller.
Moco-chan has a controller.
BAU BAU!
No, not tonight.
This weekend.
But for the sports festival, we're on the Red Team!
Akagumi!
We had a lot of fun practicing with our senpai the other day, so even though it's a serious competition, we can't wait to have more fun together.
You know it!
Towa-senpai was really, really cool and so sweet too.
We'd really like to be able to talk to him more.
Moco-chan, do you think your shoulders are ready to carry Calli-senpai during the shoulder voice competition?
I think we can do it.
There's two of us.
It'll be good.
Yeah, the toll of death is heavy.
Well, we'll give it our all!
And we'll have lots of fun with it!
I don't know, I feel like it's very appropriate for demon guard dogs to be carrying, you know?
Yeah, true, true, true.
We'll have to do our best!
And then after that, we vaaaaa!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for the very first FUWAMOCO Morning of November!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Extra Special Ruffians!
Passcode Events!
BAU BAU!
Zeke!
Lucas!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO